so wir müssten finde ich wirklich mal
anfangen die korona lasten gerechter zu
verteilen
manchen wird hier offensichtlich
deutliche afrika geholfen als anderen
diese woche gab schon wieder ein auto
gipfel im kanzleramt beziehungsweise im
house of cars natürlich als video
konferenz damit man umweltministerin
svenja schulze jederzeit stumm schalten
kann die autobauer verlangen haben sie
bestimmt gelesen die nächste kaufprämie
dabei bräuchten wir erstmal maßnahmen
die der ganzen wirtschaft helfen mit mit
welcher dreistigkeit diese leute ihre
privilegien geradezu einfordern
wir haben schon sorge dass natürlich
jetzt nicht das auto nicht der erste
gedanke viele unsere potenziellen kunden
lässt und würden uns deswegen freuen
wenn sich die politik politik mit dem
gedanken auseinandersetzen stimmte eben
auch für consumer anreizen zu sorgen
genau denn nichts hilft so gut gegen
existenzangst wie der geruch eines
neuwagens jede wette die großen drei
kriegen am ende wieder ihre blöde
kaufprämie natürlich natürlich die
entscheidung darüber hat der autogipfel
zwar erstmal auf juni vertagt aber das
kommt schwierig ihn ja meine wofür lasse
ich denn die bürger aus dem lock da und
wenn nicht so autos kaufen weiß auch der
vizekönig von bayern den wert zu hause
in der wohnung sitzung nicht rausdorf
der kauft auch kein neues auto aber wenn
man wieder raus dorf immer wieder im
biergarten darf wenn man wieder seine
freunde treffen darf wenn man wieder zur
roma vorn dorf dann kauft man auch
wieder ein neues auto sehe ich gar nicht
ein sondern sich normal doch neues auto
kauft ernsthaft vorbild ist natürlich
die berühmte abwrackprämie von 2009
wir erinnern uns dabei war die ein arsch
teures fiasko und zwar ökologisch und
ökonomisch wurscht wir machen das noch
mal so sehen das zumindest die drei
besten freunde des stifters die herren
söder kretschmann und weil ja als
mächtige herrscher der drei auto länder
haben die drei diese woche sogar ihren
eigenen kfz gipfel veranstaltet worauf
haben sich der grüne kretschmann könnte
weil
und der sensible und schwarze ist wieder
verständigt es klingt wie bei
schwiegertochter gesucht samstag saugt
der sensible söder sein suv
ich kann ihnen schon mal sagen worauf
die sich geeinigt haben auf exakt das
was deutschlands autobauer wollen
wirklich wörtlich abgeschrieben vom
wunschzettel der lobbyisten kaufprämien
und zwar nicht nur für e autos sondern
wir sprachen schon drüber auch für
verbrennern könnte so dass ich
eigentlich noch selber zu das
zusammengenommen bedeutet also nicht
4000 euro prämie drauf wenn du gleich
ein ganz hochwertiges neues
klimafreundliches auto kaufst du
bekommst 3000 braucht wenn du einen der
modernsten verbrenner fährst mit der
umstiegs option 1000 euro zu bekommen
wenn der umtausch im nächsten zwei
jahren erfolgt und wenn es jemand auch
noch sein altes auto von eur 3 euro 4 in
bereiche gibt es 2.000 euro noch dazu
nochmals ja was ist denn hier los
schickt ein arsch sofort ins auto aus
jetzt nicht kauft ist doch rot grün
der windige gebrauchtwagenhändler söder
meint das ernst 3000 euro steuergeld für
jeden neuen verbrenner jetzt was auf
wenn ich den aber direkt nach drei tagen
wieder verschrottet noch mal 1000 bin
ich bei 4.000 dann hole ich mir ein
neues elektroauto und kriege sogar
10.000 ob macht 14.000 so und als
eigenheimbesitzer zeit mir der staat
kein witz wenn es nach autolobby und
söder geht die hälfte für meine private
ladestation dann ziemlich natürlich die
garage ab und muss dank der
versicherungsprämie nie mehr arbeiten ja
was er nicht ablehnen so frage wer hilft
derweil eigentlich den öffentlichen
nahverkehr
er bräuchte gerade bringenden
schutzschirm es gibt so viele branchen
denen keiner hilft das gilt zum beispiel
auch für kartoffeln die zukunft weiter
verarbeitet werden bauernpräsident
rukwied fordert darlehen und hilfen vom
bund der warnte im tagesspiegel heute
sogar vor einer pommes krise so jetzt
reicht's ab jetzt ist corona persönlich
pommes krise wir haben eine pommes krise
ich finde übrigens so dass man nicht
völlig ernst alle selbständigen alle
selbstständigen in deutschland sollten
genau so unverschämt auftreten wie
unsere autoindustrie
hallo willkommen in holzstäbchen ob
hochzeit party oder feste hollis kneipe
ist die beste rabatt logisch jetzt
deutscher staat im gastgewerbe arbeiten
auch millionen menschen wir wollen
dasselbe was die autofokus kriegen
kaufprämie stadt kaufprämie ich verlange
für jedes 20 cent vom staat
und wenn man das verschrottet und je in
ein richtiges bier aus dem pilz
eintauscht noch mal 30 cent ja auch wir
sind absolut systemrelevant
viele alkoholiker könnten sterben wenn
ich nicht bald wieder aufmache mir würde
es völlig reichen
wenn der staat wie bei der lufthansa mit
nur zehn milliarden beim er einsteigt
dann wäre ich aus dem gröbsten raus und
könnte vielleicht sogar
[Musik]
lassen
wir haben sogar ein hygiene konzept
frikadellen zum beispiel werden
neuerdings nach nur einer woche
weggeworfen
da drehte auch leben und wir trainieren
schon das servieren unter corona
bedingungen so aber die schweinshaxe und
zwei schnaps aus
guten appetit in diesem sinne liebe olaf
scholz meine kontonummer wird nun unten
eingeblendet wir sehen uns in hall die
skulls stübchen dann sehen wir uns in
jedem fall bei holger stockhaus so eine
andere frage ist unter welchen
bedingungen hilft der staat vw daimler
und co fordern milliarden hilfen und
schütten trotzdem dividenden an ihre
aktionäre aus die erkennen da überhaupt
keinen widerspruch in nachbarländern von
uns sieht man das übrigens deutlich
anders frankreich ist da schon weiter
keine dividende bei kurzarbeitergeld
heißt es da kategorisch und dänemark
dreht den spieß ganz einfach um der
dividende zahlt bekommt keine
staatshilfe
das sei sozial so nämlich asozial
beziehungsweise antisozial auch wir
deutschen hätten in unser neues
wirtschaft stabilisierungsfonds gesetz
ähnliche bedingungen reinschreiben
können wenn staatshilfe dann keine
dividenden feierabend und wären
steuervermeidung tricks arbeitet der
kriegt auch nichts schön wär's bmw hat
finanzgesellschaften zb in irland
luxemburg oder malta aus steuerlichen
gründen bmw teilt dazu mit insbesondere
in krisenzeiten ist es wichtig auf ein
global agierendes liquiditätsmanagement
zugreifen zu können
absolut liquiditäts manager zu meiner
zeit ist das normal keeper bmw sagt also
sinngemäß wir machen das nicht zum
steuersparen wir machen das damit wir
mehr geld haben
lufthansa will auch milliarden vom staat
wissen sie hat aber tochterunternehmen
in panama und auf den cayman inseln mit
folgender ausrede zitat wir gründen
tochtergesellschaften nur da wo dies aus
operativen gründen geboten ist fun fact
die lufthansa fliegt die kaimaninseln
gar nicht an
ja tatsächlich sind sämtliche dax
konzerne nach wie vor in steueroasen
sehr präsent und das ist irgendwie
bedrückend wenn man bedenkt wie oft wir
über diese schweinerei schon geredet
haben auch in dieser sendung weil er aus
betreibt auf den cayman-inseln das
weltweit erste geld reisebüro von hier
aus was ist denn ein geld reisebüro dass
die beste idee die ich je hatte herr
welke wir deutschen dürfen ja keinen
urlaub mehr machen an exotischen
stränden aber wir können unser geld
dahin schicken
am besten in länder wo es nicht weniger
wird warum soll so geld mich auch mal in
die sonne die seele baumeln lassen
unbehelligt von blöden finanzämtern
buchen sie jetzt ihre traumreise bei
secret money escapes wissen sie
eigentlich dürfte mein geld gar nicht
hier sein denn meine konzerngewinne
theoretisch müsste ich die in
deutschland versteuern mache ich
natürlich nicht und jetzt kommt der
hammer ich habe ernsthaft staatshilfen
beantragt von demselben start den ich
bescheid wissen sie mein geld dürfte
auch nicht hier sein
aber deutschland ist halt echt dämlich
macht das alles mit also na ja ganz so
einfach ist
sigrid marias games jetzt bis zu hundert
prozent steuern sparen
vollpension und voll egal
allein in diesen briefkasten haben 30
deutschen dax-konzerne eine tochterfirma
arbeiten sehr kleine mitarbeiter illegal
aber asozial unsere dax unternehmen
kommen aktuell auf fast 4000
beteiligungen oder töchter in
steuerparadiesen also vorsicht herr
welke briefkastenfirmen dienen eben
nicht nur der steuervermeidung die kann
man für alles mögliche gebrauchen
es geht also nicht nur um
steuerhinterziehung es geht darum andere
delikte
es geht um drogenhandel waffenhandel es
geht auch darum vielleicht den unterhalt
eines unehelichen kindes zu sichern dass
ich mit der sekretärin gezeugt habe all
diese dinge lassen sich wunderbar über
eine briefkastenfirma abwickeln wer
denkt denn sonst an die ganzen drogen
und waffenhändler mit unehelichen
kindern keiner da sind unsere schulden
wieder in bester gesellschaft
ich rate meinen kunden wirklich jetzt
buchen bevor im herbst die steuern
erhöht werden wenn olaf scholz merkt
dass sein geld alle ist dann muss die
ihr geld längst an einem besseren ort
sein herr welke können sie alles
nachlesen
in diesem kinderbuch oh wie schön
niedrig ist der steuersatz in panama
gutes stichwort was haben wir eigentlich
aus den letzten steuer skandalen gelernt
riesenaufregung nach luchs nix und
panama papers und passiert ist nichts
ob das stimmt doch gar nicht nach luchs
nix sind mehrere whistleblower
juristisch verfolgt worden zu recht die
elenden petzen und seitdem panama papers
wird fieberhaft ermittelt das dauert
halt nur wenn ich ihnen sagen würde dass
wir 271.000 gesellschaften haben und ein
ermittler bei einer grob sichtung vier
gesellschaften am tag schafft dann kann
man sehr leicht ausrechnen dass wir
circa 67 fast 68.000 tage brauchen
würden um alle daten zu sichten
umgerechnet auf arbeitstage während das
3 107 jahre
das wäre dann im jahr 2003 127 übrigens
auch das jahr in dem die korona app der
bundesregierung fertig wird
alles so bitter zumal die deutsche
steuerfahndung gerade wegen solcher
komplett ausfällt keine razzien keine
vernehmung ist optimal für ihre kunden
haben die kaimaninseln eigentlich gar
keine steuerfahnder zu hoch da kommt
gerade ein
nach meiner rechnung ist er in 307
jahren hier also da muss ich echt gucken
dass ich rechtzeitig komme valerie
niehaus und und alles sobald wir eine
millionen abonnenten haben liebe liebe
liebe fans ich würde mich so was schon
freuen wenn ihr ein abo dallas braucht
er würde den gern ist so was von
glücklich machen